president biden he is one day away from
what could be the biggest foreign policy
test of his presidency so far a
face-to-face meeting
with russian president vladimir putin in
switzerland
they last met 10 years ago when mr biden
was vice president
since then russia has taken a series of
aggressive actions
including interfering with u.s elections
a cbs news poll shows most americans 58
percent
want the president to take a tough stand
with putin
as he's promised to do 41 percent say
the recent wave of
cyber attacks on the united states is
the most important
issue to address nancy cordes is in
brussels forest where president biden is
meeting with
european leaders today nancy good
morning to you good morning there's a
point to president biden
meeting with all these allies before he
sits down
with president putin mr biden wants to
demonstrate
that he is going into this summit with
the west
entirely united behind him in fact
he told me that some of the leaders he
met with
wish that he had met with putin even
sooner
he's bright he's tough president biden
told us he's prepping for his meeting
with vladimir putin by
seeking input from nato allies here in
brussels
i had discussions with them about what
they thought
was important from their perspective the
putin summit comes in the wake of cyber
attacks on u.s infrastructure
by criminals likely based in russia
putin laughed off the allegations in a
recent interview
where is the evidence where is proof
president biden said he'll also confront
putin about his invasion of neighboring
ukraine
have any of the world leaders you've met
with this week expressed concern that by
meeting with
president putin this early in your
presidency that it'll look like you're
rewarding him
every world leader here as a member of
nato
that spoke today and most of them
mentioned it thanked me
another topic likely to come up russia's
record on human rights
and particularly the fate of jailed
opposition leader alexei navalny
putin would not guarantee his critic
will leave prison alive
and so i asked mr biden what it will
mean
for the u.s russia relationship if
alexei navali
were to die or be killed in prison it
would do nothing
but hurt his relationships with
the rest of the world in my view and
with me president biden and the other
nato leaders also
issued a tough new stance on china
saying the country's assertive behavior
presents challenges to the rules-based
international order
but it's russian cyber hacking that
worries many
u.s businesses it came up over and over
again commerce secretary gina raimondo
met with executives from
about 20 companies here in europe
yesterday
as the bad guys become more
sophisticated so do we need to become
more sophisticated and so it's
it's really a call to action for the
private sector to step up its game
i asked secretary raymondo how expensive
it is for companies to protect
themselves she said it's actually
less expensive than dealing with the
fallout from being hacked
but she acknowledged that no security
system is
foolproof which is why president biden
is hoping to make some headway on this
issue
when he sits down with president putin
tomorrow tony and why it's so important
nancy cordes for us in brussels nancy
thank you very much